Britain has a long history of inventing
brilliant new technologies,
processes,
and designs,
but how do we make sure these
innovations translate into money making
products,
companies and industries?
What is needed in today's turbulent
economic climate to turn British
startups into world beaters?
Entrepreneurial Spirit is high.
At the beginning of 2012 4.8 million
startups were operating in the UK an
increase of over 200,000 firms on the
previous year.
Securing funding is a real challenge.
In a recent survey,
more than six out of 10 small businesses
said lack of startup capital was the
barrier they found hardest to overcome.
So what next?
In the USA there has been a surge in
crowdfunding.
The website kickstarter has raised more
than $660 million for 43,000 product
offerings and over 4 million people have
contributed money in the UK exit of
based crowd cube has 37,000 registered
investors and has raised over 9 million
pounds.
Venture capital is also important for
inspiration.
British policy makers could look to
Israel,
which attracts more than twice as much
venture capital per capita than any
other country at $170 per person.
With this model,
Israel has established a world leading
high tech startup culture,
impressive for a country of just 7
million,
but while venture capital and crowd
funding are important,
big business has a role to play.
Large firms in Britain have as much as
750 billion pounds held in reserve.
Many I helping to incubate startups by
offering a mix of funding,
contacts,
office space and mentoring as part of
initiative such as London's tank city.
Shell's springboard is a UK based social
investment program founded in 2005
springboard aims to find the UKS next
big idea in low carbon enterprise and
innovation.
Every year it's a wards 330,000 pounds
to innovative and commercially viable
business ideas that aim to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions and the last
eight years,
the initiative has award in 2.2 5
million pounds to 62 businesses.
Shell livewire is another source of
support for Young UK entrepreneurs.
It offers free online business advice
and startup awards of 1000 pounds and
10,000 pounds.
Two it's 200,000 members.
Funding is just one element of starting
a business.
Click on the link below to watch the
latest switched on event where for
innovators highlights the hurdles they
had to overcome and what needs to be
done to ensure UK businesses become
world beaters.